okay pop quiz
what
am i drawing
i'm gonna make
three predictions here
firstly
you can go to a house you'd be right
secondly
that it just came really easily to you
as effortless and thirdly you're
thinking that i'm not much of an artist
and you'd be right on all counts there
but how can we look at this set of
geometric shapes and think oh
a house
if you live in a house i bet it looks
nothing like this well that ability to
perform object identification that comes
so easily to us
does not come so easily to a computer
but that is where we can apply something
called convolutional
neural networks
to the problem
now a convolutional neural network or a
cnn
is a area of deep learning that
specializes in pattern recognition
my name is martin keane and i work in
the ibm garage at ibm
now let's take a look
at how cnn works at a high level
well let's break it down cnn
convolutional neural network well let's
start with the
artificial neural network part
this is a standard network that consists
of multiple layers that are
interconnected
and each layer receives some input
transforms that input to something else
and passes it as output to the next
layer that's how neural networks work
and cnn is a particular part of the
neural network or a section of layers
let's say it's these three layers here
and within these layers we have
something called filters
and it's the filters that perform
the
pattern recognition that cnn is so good
at
so
let's apply this to our house example
now if this house were an actual image
it would be
a series of pixels just like any image
and if we zoom in on a particular part
of this house let's say we zoom in
around here then we would get well
the window
and what we're saying here is that a
window consists of some perfectly
straight lines
almost perfectly straight lines but you
know a window doesn't need to look like
that a window could equally kind of look
like this and we would still say it was
a window
the cool thing about cnn is that using
filters cnn could also say that these
two objects represent the same thing
the way they do that then is through the
application of these filters so let's
take a look at how that works
now a filter is basically
just a three by three block and within
that block we can specify a pattern to
look for
so we could say let's look for
pattern like this a right angle
in our image
so we do is we take this filter and it's
a three by three block here we will
analyze the equivalent three by three
block up here as well
so
we'll look at first of all these first
group of three by three pixels and we
will see how close are they to the
filter shape
and we'll give that a numeric score
then we will move across one column to
the right and look at the next three by
three block of pixels and score how
close they are to the filter shape and
we will continue to slide over or
convolve
over all of these pixel layers until we
have mapped every three by three block
now that's just for one filter but what
that will give us is an array of numbers
that say how closely an image
matches our filter
but we can add more filters so we could
add another three by three filter here
and perhaps this one looks for a shape
like this
and we could add a third filter here
and perhaps this looks for a different
kind of right angle shape
if we take the numeric arrays from all
of these filters and combine them
together in a process called pooling
then we have a much better understanding
of
what is contained within this series of
pixels
now that's just the first layer of the
cnn and as we go deeper into the neural
network the filters become more abstract
or they can do more
so
the second layer of filters perhaps can
perform tasks like basic object
recognition
so we could have filters here that might
be able to recognize the presence of a
window
or the presence of a door or the
presence
of a roof
and as we go deeper into the cnn to the
next layer well maybe these filters can
perform even more abstract tasks like
being able to determine whether we're
looking at a house
or we're looking at an apartment
or whether we're looking at a skyscraper
so you can see the application of these
filters
increases as we go through the network
and can perform more and more tasks and
that's a very high level basic overview
of what cnn is it has a ton of business
applications think of ocr for example
for understanding handwritten documents
think of visual recognition and facial
detection and visual search
think of medical imagery and looking at
that and determining what is being shown
in an imaging scan and even think of the
fact that we can apply a cnn to perform
object identification for
badly drawn houses
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching